right now it takes about one year for VA
to process a new claim that is simply no
way to treat a wounded soldier coming
back from a war we're constantly
receiving indirect fire from 2008-2009
and we had taken a direct hit retired
naval commander Jake Schneider has
suffered multiple injuries throughout
his 22-year military career the most
recent being a traumatic brain injury
sustained while in Iraq over two million
Americans have been deployed in the last
12 years to fight the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan
Jake is among the thousands injured who
have returned home only to face another
battle with the Department of Veterans
Affairs the VA is the second largest
federal department and is responsible
for providing care and benefits to US
veterans during the enlistment process a
recruit is told that should a service
related injury occur the US government
will provide financial assistance in
accordance to the severity of the injury
however the VA hasn't been able to
fulfill that promise in a timely manner
causing emotional and financial
hardships in the veteran community quite
frankly most people don't know VA has
received more than 800,000 disability
claims from Iraq and Afghanistan war
veterans and Congress and VA planned for
zero the Obama administration considers
any claim that has been pending for more
than 125 days to be backlog as of August
2013 the VA reported almost 800,000
pending claims with 63 percent of them
backlogged this is down from March when
nearly 900,000 claims were pending with
70% of them backlog the VA argues that
these numbers shown improvement however
reports of an increase in errors among
processing claims indicates a poor
quality of work VA makes a mistake in 30
percent or more of the cases that they
decide that means veterans have to
appeal and when a veteran appeals he or
she waits four more years for an answer
from the
veterans fears the root causes are a
failure within VA leadership to plan for
large increases in claims the ability to
receive what's due it makes a difference
a few hundred dollars $300 makes a big
dent you know and a lot of a lot of
lives a lot of families Jake had to wait
one year before receiving partial VA
compensation he has not been able to
receive his full benefits yet because
the VA mismanaged his paperwork this has
caused him financial stress I don't know
how much longer I can keep going
va claim backlog does exacerbate the
mental health of a veteran who is
already suffering from problems related
to the war we have 22 veterans a day
that are committed suicide part of the
contributing factor is part and parcel
to the veterans that are being delayed
denied this is very serious these
veterans earn those benefits for getting
wounded or injured well in the military
and for the country to say that we can't
take care of those who defended our
Constitution and our country we are
headed for a very serious crisis
you